the S&R show comprises 10 days of
creative tuning and classic cars galore
this year the event turns fifty reason
enough for celebrations the fireworks
were provided by this jet-powered School
Bus
[Music]
not so much love you can't sleep at
nights his former drag racer get Hobart
man you come up with really silly or
spectacular ideas he's been drag racing
for 38 years and has a number of jet
powered vehicles the school bus is
something special kids would love going
to school if they were picked up in this
bus this idea one took several years to
develop and here is the result about
Buster this is like a penis in fact
there are no seats for the kids they had
to make way for the westinghouse j34
turbojet engine it runs on jet fuel
generates 25,000 horsepower and comes
with two drag parishes
also on exhibit is this oddity from
Britain thinking west can be more Paul
Byrd hack 3 1 centimeters off his 1989
go to GTI and welded the rear back on
his ten-year-old VW Beetle has also had
some surgery
it had a 66 centimeter section and its
middle removed the doors also had to be
downsized to fit as did the side sills
but stealing the show on a regular basis
over the years have been the Rinspeed
prototypes from swiss visionary funk in
that connection this masterpiece is
called the Oasis it's self driving and
for a relaxing vibe while on the road as
a miniature garden on the dashboard
for music fans there was this little
card jam-packed with speakers for some
people the sound can never be too loud
[Music]
the show also featured this funky
version of the VW Passat
it has Recaro bucket seats and a body
colored roll cage this Opel Corsa C was
also hard to recognize the whole
interior has been lined with black and
orange leather and also has a range of
carbon fiber details and two of course
has anti-roll bars
Vica has been seeing quite a lot more
interior customizing recently he could
easily imagine the trend being taken up
by the professional tuners it occurs
quite often that private initiatives end
up as commercial trends but starting
bellman-ford took the opportunity to
unveil the new racing version of its
Mustang GT 4 at the s in Motor Show in
2016 the cold Pony car was the
best-selling sports car in the world a
special show titled 50 years of super
sports cars featured this bugatti chiron
with a price tag of some 4 million euros
the most expensive car at the show it's
a new car but only 150 will ever be
built making it a coveted collector's
item right off the assembly line
another high-priced rarity is this
Pagani who I Ribisi 50 were built and
this is the only one currently offered
for sale anywhere price 2 million euros
[Music]
this rolls-royce 2025 HP with the Hooper
body is the oldest vehicle at the show
it was built in 1934
[Music]
the VW Beetle has been a darling of many
generations now the nearly half century
old bug has received an especially
colorful paint job from professional
tuner Frances Ouma she customized and
rebuilt almost everything about it the
fenders headlights and windows
[Music]
among the cars on display in Essen are
Hollywood celebrities this Eleanor
Shelby is the original car used in Gone
in sixty Seconds with Nicolas Cage
behind the wheel
[Music]
Batman is here too I mercedes-amg stand
with the original movie Batmobile from
Justice League and the essent motor
shows 50th year horse power teams up
with emotion for 10 days of fun for
young and old
over 500 exhibitors welcomed more than
350,000 fair goers
[Music]
you